investigation into what he calls putin's
palace on russia's black sea coast
has now had 112 million views
[Music]
a recent poll found that one in four
russians has seen it
but a third of them don't believe it
the message that these are simulations
based on detailed floor plans and
furniture commissions leaked to
navalny's team
not quite landing the state's
propagandists have hit back hard
saying navalny was brought in just for
the voiceover
speedster
then one of putin's oldest pals arkady
rottenberg told news outlet mash that it
belonged to him
and he would turn it into a hotel
so why still the tight security a border
control post bang next door a no-fly
zone up above
and a no from rotenberg on access
on the right here there is a barrier
beyond which it seems we cannot pass
to putin's palace or should i say
rottenberg's hotel
is the nearest village pavel chatelbash
says he's always voted for vladimir
putin
and he thinks he should have as many
residences as he wants
officers after they spoke to journalists
the day before
but he's still surprisingly frank
he's not alone in thinking that even
here this was in genji
the nearest town to the palace on the
first day of protest called by navalny's
team
chattelbash thinks the nationwide
protests too were instigated by the west
coast
you and that's just it the promise of
stability over upheaval
putin's usp it explains the continued
support for the russian president
among those living on meager pensions
the only
[Applause]
and why calls for freedom resonate only
briefly
and falteringly across the largest
country on earth
dinah magnay sky news gillen jig russia